okay everyone one of the most
interesting characters to watch an
Avengers infinity war was star-lord
Peter quill aka Guardians Chris we're
gonna be touching on plot point in the
movie here
so again spoiler warning go watch the
movie great you're back okay and
Avengers infinity war 1 really the
thrilling fight sequence for me showed
the Avengers come closer than ever to
actually getting the best of Thanos on
Titan Iron Man spider-man Doctor Strange
star-lord Drax mantis and nebula combine
their strengths to restrain Thanos
trapping him in a near comatose state as
Iron Man at spider-man tried to pull off
the Infinity Gauntlet from its hand
spider-man comes agonizingly close we
see that thing regal and slide by the
way we see it's a size of entirety of
Peter Parker at this same moment
star-lord realizes what Thanos did to
acquire the soul stone sacrificed Gamora
Peter quill loses it to any attacks
Thanos breaking him out of that
restraint allowing him to fight back
each of the Avengers and then Thanos
throws a moan at them and he overwhelms
Stark and it gets the time stone then he
pieces out back to earth where he uses
that time stone to reverse Scarlet Witch
destroy and vanished visions mine stone
had he not gotten time stone he never
would have gotten the mine stone he
never would gotten all six his master
plan would have been foiled
so this brings up the question guys is
this all star Lords fault
or you believe star-lord kept his cool
and stomached his grief they could have
gotten the gauntlet and Thanos would
have been finished star-lord and the
other unlucky unlucky half of the
universe would still be here I don't
know guys how much do you think
star-lord is to blame is this impulsive
anguish over Gamora worth this mistake
it's 100% his fault completely entirely
uh there's no doubt about the fact that
this moment is his fault that they lose
that moment mm-hmm that moment is his
fault but I'll say that in all of the
possibilities of what could have
happened that Doctor Strange perceived
if it's over 14 million he had to
absolutely gain the time stone in this
moment we see it again shown when he
trade Stark's life for it I feel like
this is actually
dr. strange allowing certain things to
happen we need him to hold on to the
gauntlet and he needs to leave here with
the time stone it's one of its the only
of the versions that it will possibly
happen this is the only one but we will
eventually win even though we'll lose
right now so do you think the Doctor
Strange knew that and did not share the
entire thing cuz he knew star lore was
gonna react that way I think so I think
there's no way they could have told the
team it's like you're gonna try real
hard but then star wars gonna mess it up
for all of its sleep it involves
star-lord eventually being one of the
people to fade away right and I think
that answer comes also in that moment
where Tony's like what you let me lit
like we're not even y'all kind of that
way a little right didn't it feel like
for a second it's like doesn't it feel
earned it didn't feel like it but he's
now my best friend so I you know we
don't trade live or something it didn't
feel like that in that moment it's
because Doctor Strange is playing four
dimensional test but you know what I
mean yes totally on another level and
he's allowing events to take place
including letting him mess things up in
that moment for me I didn't think that
that specific part was planned I think
this was a genuine mistake that that
does actually you do bring up a good
point if you saw 14 million outcomes
there's not one where star-lord freaked
out but he found out his girlfriend got
killed by her dad but in from the way I
interpret it watching it like then now
you bring up a good point but after I
saw the movie I thought that honestly
this was just an outcome he hadn't seen
just yet and star-lord freaking out did
ruin the one way they could have gotten
out of this and in his and all the
futures he saw he saw that Tony Stark
might be the only one that could like
not it could be one of the only people
to figure out how to undo this so that's
why he's like we can't let him die
because he's one of our only hopes yeah
super fascinating possibility and it's
it's really answered by a year belief of
your own answer here to the question did
he mean there's one time where we win
this thing now or on the other side of
half the people vanishing
we win at the end of infinity war - I
think he was looking at immediate
there's a it's kind of hard to look at
like already when he said 14 million
like way too many times you look there
way too many futures that they just
picked a big number of the writers dead
and I feel like it was more immediate
but you do bring up a good point
so just depend it's it's interesting how
much do you want to consider dr. strange
to be omniscient and a God in this movie
as the screenwriter and the director of
the movie you're kind of a god you
decide who comes in when and how these
events unfold and I was thinking about
this like oh why have nebula come back
and oh they needed nebula to be in the
scene in this moment so that she could
confirm that Gamora died because she was
part of that conversation earlier but if
the screenwriter knew that like I have a
feeling strange would know that as well
he knew that nebula needed to crash her
ship him to Titan in this moment and
help them restraint the Annis or a
moment but he also knew that that would
involve her sharing that information
with star-lord and that that could cause
chaos I think that vision yeah I think
it's very possible that star that Doctor
Strange saw in this one timeline in the
future where things work nebula in Tony
Stark I think the way the screenwriters
paired things down to just have the
essential members of the MCU there in
that final battle I think that's what
strange saw as well we're only gonna
have the people were still alive who
need to be there to actually take damage
down in the end brain but I'm not gonna
leave what you said if he's omniscient
if the eye of agamotto gives him the
ability to see all eventualities but if
he's again like Nicholas Cage in the
movie next and he can only see just a
few minutes ahead and he saw 14 million
we could argue that from star-lords
point of view a very selfish move
especially since he had several scenes
with Gamora where he was arguing on
whether or not he would kill her he
pulled the trigger
unfortunately bubbles came out and very
cartoonish hilarious way he was totally
ready to kill her and it seems like he
should have already detached himself at
least on a slight emotional level so
that when he's confronted with saving
half the known universe he can at least
hold that back but more taking a swing
at the guy maybe I I kind of agree yes
it is his fault I do agree
because actually just when you think
about it's like yeah 100% it's his fault
but also I do like the perspective of
like know the endgame when he mentions
this is the endgame now it's that this
is the this is the last this is the you
have to complete what's gonna happen
next I gave you everything that you can
possibly know and have it your in your
arsenal and you can do this yeah so I do
like I do think your theory is more
correct we can also talk this up to like
in war just things happen nothing should
ever go to plan right it's a little bit
more insane to see it's way more
interesting I would say to see Peter
quill screw up this place in the movie
and we're not talking about did he trip
on a rock he did something that his
character chose to do or maybe didn't
even chose just to do because of the
thing most important to him in the world
was gone or in the universe really was
gone so he doesn't really have a great
reason to save the universe as much he
used to in that moment and the thing
that did it is right there in that
moment so they definitely justified it
so we don't necessarily need to even say
the wrong thing
and I'll give you a twist on the same
question it could go all the way the
other way if Doctor Strange was right
this is the one time then is them
winning at the end of infinity war to
Peter Quill's fault oh yeah you could
yeah you could have these thought
experiments in infinite ways it's just
my plan that's kind of yeah if it came
back around that way it was at least at
least like Danis didn't sit on his
mixtape volume 2 and that's why he was
pissed off well let us know what you
think in the comments down below and
reminder to subscribe to the new rock
stars for all of our Infinity Ward
coverage
thanks guys